toujours ça c'est trop bien saas et
cloud basé marcouiller je te connais
alors alex toi tu veux un truc aussi
dans ton spectacle parce que ça rejoint
un petit peu ce qu'a fait philippe tu
parles des chanteurs de télé crochet qui
sont très tristes
alors je suis allé mais parce que ça
fait pas sympa non mais si c'est pas
grave non parce que quand ils sont trop
c'est drôle et des fois ils se rendent
pas compte de la signification de ce
qu'il chante ouais c'est ça un jour quoi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et à coup sûr tout à fait capable de
tata yoyo
oui parce que tu as le grand chapeau
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le problème d'une mini question c'est
que ça même elle aime ça n'amène pas une
mini réponses souvent donc là mais très
rapide on jouera la fille j'adore cette
affiche je passe tout le temps devant s
cube d'air non est-ce que vous avez payé
des droits est ce que vous avez le droit
à ce que non on avait pris le rina
kinder on a pris le risque comme elles
mêmes mais j'ai eu un jour en tournée un
mec qui était habillé comme un
inspecteur de police si il m'a dit qu'il
travaillait chez chez vous ne pigez il
m'a dit je parie chez ferrero alors
cette idée d' affiches super bon
salariat plus jamais une nouvelle en
plus c'est en tout cas il n'y a jamais
eu de jamais eu de problème mais c'est
sympa si vous écrivez une bio en tout
cas cette anecdote mettez là dedans
[Applaudissements]
brett est comme ça c'est l'anecdote la
plus confondre il s'est arrêté il a dit
bon et pas d'agrémenter plus que ça no
vous enfoncez pas si parce que j'essaye
de dire on s'en fout elle est sympa il
des kinder à l'entré deux lacs
oui donc j'aimerais bien qu'il me fasse
à un petite ristourne ouais bah oui j'ai
dû pinguins mois tombé du camion
s'il veut s'il veut que la roche sur les
kinder penguins peut être là on a parlé
de classe